it took me some time to work out when I
was given the instruction okay this is
what we'd like you to do they said this
is a spoken-- celebration of what it
means to be Australian and I thought
that is an amazing privilege and
completely unhelpful because it could be
anything but that's part of the joy so
what will your speech on Australia Day
be focusing on I have a few themes that
I want to address in the first one
obviously as a teacher is the importance
and value of education and working in a
school is a wonderful privilege it's
also one of the hardest jobs that there
is and our culture understands the
importance of schools but often doesn't
appreciate the actual work that's
happening with classrooms and students
all around the country why we're on that
you're talking our viewers can see some
pictures here and I think this is from
your YouTube site woo tube which I
understand you set up because you had a
six student I know you wanted to be able
to teach math too now for those that
might have missed it you had an
Australian story we featured in an
Australian story in fact if I'm I'm hope
I'm correct I think it was the most
watch Australian story for last year you
had the highest number which should be I
mean it's an incredible privilege
obviously to be included on something
like that but yeah it would be amazing
to but I think it really hit home
because for many generations I think
people lots of people have struggled
with maths and they haven't been able to
get into maths and how probably hasn't
been seen as a cool thing but you
certainly have have made it that matters
a bit of a paradox I mean we sort of all
know it's something kind of important
and that's why we make it compulsory for
10 11 years of our children's education
but it's really hard it's a hard subject
it's hard for people to grapple with
so as maths had a bad name without doubt
mathematics if you want to put a movie
down and have a character who's having a
bad time in school you put them in their
mathematics classroom it's kind of a bit
of a cultural trope and I think that one
of the things I'm trying to do is help
people understand what mathematics
really is I don't think the bad name is
deserved
so then as a teacher how do you think
how do you get children that
traditionally have probably not
interested in math and that would have
been someone like myself how do you get
them interested
in math well I like to think about it
this way I have some I've got children
they're four seven and nine and you
don't need to teach a toddler that it's
fun to solve a jigsaw puzzle or to come
up with an answer to something which is
perplexing to them they're curious they
want to know and I think we all start
that way but mathematics needs to be
learned as a personal journey and many
people think of it as a objective try
boring an unemotional subject and so one
of the main ways that I connect with
students is to get alongside them and
say look this connects to your life and
understanding it will reach in the way
you think of the world so making it much
more practical practical is one thing
but also there are parts of mathematics
that aren't practical and are just
interesting and will help you see okay
you know when you listen to music so
much of music is mathematical and it
doesn't have to be have a practical
purpose in that it just helps us enjoy
that more deeply now I understand that
your speech is also going to be focusing
on looking at different viewpoints as
you as an australian-born child of
migrants Malaysian Chinese how has this
helped your upbringing and your parents
being in migrants how has this helped or
formed you know your values and and what
you've been doing in your life one of
the things I think is central to
Australian culture is giving everyone a
fair go and the importance of hard work
which is more decisive than you know say
your raw talent and I think that's
something which is really wonderful
about Australian culture and we say you
know what everyone deserves a shot and
everyone deserves the opportunities to
be able to take whatever skills that
they have and work hard at them and be
useful to their communities and as a son
of a migrant that's something which is
inherent to why my parents came here to
this country and today an education for
you would have been extremely important
education really was in a single word
the reason why my parents came here
because they knew there's universal
education in that public schools so many
of them are excellent and can provide a
world-class education which is a
platform to the entire world now I'm
assuming you probably could have done
anything you wanted to any less school
why did you choose the path of teaching
and you've also teaching in the in the
state school system when I was at school
it was really amazing to me
quite profound to see what kind of a
profound long-term impact teachers can
have on students everyone can remember a
teacher who made a really strong impact
on them in both negative and positive
ways because we spend so much time at
school and there's such an investment in
people's personality and helping them
grow in skills and so when I thought
okay what am I going to do with my life
I want to be able to serve people and
give them something meaningful and
important and helping them understand
the way the world works helping them
wrap their head around a really
difficult subject like mathematics just
seemed like a perfect way to do that so
there's a set of migrants do you think
Australians still face big challenges
when it comes to different race and
different cultures without a doubt I
mean I was on the train coming into the
city for this and I just looked around
and saw so many different faces so many
different colors and backgrounds and of
course it's just human nature
when we encounter people who are
different to ourselves and have
different values and backgrounds and
ways of thinking and speaking it's
always going to be a challenge to
wrestle with how do I fit in with that
and how do I work together with these
people and cooperate when we come to the
table with such different opinions but
that's part of what makes Australia so
wonderful that we do that and every
generation learns afresh how important